(gentle music)
- [Narrator] In India's
capital city of New Delhi,
you'll find a cultural mix
of history and modernity.
At the heart of this intersection,
we find vendors who are
serving amazing dishes
to this city of 25 million people,
and who aren't afraid
to mess with tradition.
Starting with a classic,
stuffed with a twist.
(upbeat music)
- [Narrator] Keeping with the theme,
here's an ice cream shop
that serves its dessert
in a slightly different manner.
(upbeat music)
- [Narrator] On the west side of the city
there is a one-of-a-kind dish
elevating vegetarian food.
(gentle music)
- [Narrator] Finally, if you venture
into the older part of the city,
you'll find this traditional fruit stand,
serving up an inspired snack.
(upbeat music)
(logo chiming)